grazie luca buongiorno a tutti
il tema di cui vorrei parlare è
esattamente questo cioè capire che cosa
può portare in un dibattito che parla di
diversità di progresso il punto di vista
di chi come noi
studia i dati di chi è sempre più gente
in giro per il mondo si pone il problema
di fondare una scienza nuova passata su
sui dati che possano descrivere per la
prima volta nella storia in modo
estremamente dettagliato il
funzionamento della società tutte quelle
sorgenti di cui luca parlava prima
dell'intervento le tracce digitali che
noi lasciamo come portato del nostro
vivere dei nostri movimenti dei nostri
desideri dei nostri acquisti delle
nostre ricerche in rete
questo è il tema il nostro
l'idea di questo movimento che si va
formando è quella di arrivare da
discipline diverse dalla fisica della
complessità dall'informatica dalla
sociologia dalla statistica
dall'economia arrivare a ad avere un
nuovo strumento di indagine e un nuovo
microscopio sociale che possa
permetterci di vedere come funziona la
società che abbiamo costruito nel corso
della nostra evoluzione
abbiamo imparato moltissimo quasi tutto
sul funzionamento dell'infinitamente
grande dell'infinitamente piccolo
sappiamo pochissimo del di questo
organismo che ancora rispetto al resto
di questo organismo che abitiamo che è
la società che abbiamo costruito
forse cominciamo ad avere lo strumento
il microscopio che ci può permettere di
analizzarlo anche quantitativamente con
questa premessa vorrei dire che il
nostro lavoro spesso era far raccontare
storie i dati è il tema oggi e due brevi
storie che sono originati da dati
piccoli o grandi big small che hanno a
che fare col tema della diversità il
primo a che fare anche con
una mucca questa storia nasce con l'idea
di wisdom of the cloud l'intelligenza
della folla l'intelligenza collettiva è
una suggestione antica surfers galton
una statistico economista inglese del i
primi del novecento diciamo nel 1907
pubblica un lavoro sul network che si
chiama vox populi doveva questa idea
questa mucca un'amica come questa è il
protagonista di una gara ad una fine del
bestiame in inghilterra e la gara
consiste gli avventori provano ad
indovinare il peso dell'animale scrivono
su un foglietto e loro pronostico per le
quali è l'idea di qualcuno vince il
premio l'idea di galton è quella di a
posteriori e collezionare questi
pronostici questi foglietti con il peso
che la vacca questo diciamo la sua
analista analitica di questi 800
pronostici li mise in fila dal più
grande al più piccolo e considero il la
mediana c'è il valore che taglia la
lista a metà
se ci pensate in fondamentalmente i se
vediamo questo esperimento a posteriori
come una specie di elezione di voto
collettivo in cui una folla cerca di
indovinare collettivamente il peso
giusto dell'animale è la mediana è il
punto di massimo consenso no c'è il
massimo come dire appunto consenso
rispetto a quel valore intermedio bene
questo valore 1207 libbre circa il 5
quintali e mezzo è incredibilmente
vicino a quello vero dell'animale c'è un
po pochissima differenza prima scoperta
la seconda però ancora più importante la
seconda più importante il piego il
colore di queste bacche diverse
se noi ci limitiamo a guardare i
pronostici dei dei giocatori più esperti
cioè quelli che allevatori macellai che
hanno competenza in materia e quindi
vediamo soltanto i loro pronostici non
quelli anche degli avventori qualsiasi
che parteciparono a quella da
quell'evento sorpresa il pronostico
peggiora la mediana
l'esperimento ripetuto solo con i voti
degli esperti a un esito peggiore
più lontano dal vero pezzo della marca
la suggestione forte quindi no la
maggiore diversità di opinioni in questo
elettorato
il fatto di vedere la mucca da punti di
vista completamente diversi con
competenze diverse con storie diverse
porta maggiore intelligenza collettiva è
un'associazione ovviamente allora a
basata su pochi i dati ma moltissimi
esperimenti fatti da allora l'hanno
ripetuta la variabilità un fatto di
poter esprimere giudizi differenziati
porta maggiore capacità di rispondere a
domande come questa di valutare il
valore o il peso o una misura di un
oggetto e la cosa è ancora più
interessante scoperta recentemente è che
se immergiamo i votanti
queste sono immagini di reti sociali la
struttura delle relazioni che ci
circonda questa per esempio è una
cosiddetta ego network una rete
personale all'interno di facebook con le
comunità che ci circondano e chiaramente
questo pezzo di una rete ancora più
grande no in cui ogni persona è fino
altri all'intera diciamo struttura
globale
questa è una figura che raffigura
diciamo su scala geografica le reti di
relazioni di facebook bene l'esperimento
fatto su questi su diciamo una
simulazione al computer di questi di
questi legami e dell'influenza che
possono avere su una platea di votanti
che cercano di fare un gioco come quello
di prima è fortemente negativa cioè le
influenze che riducono la diversità che
portano visioni in qualche modo
conformistiche rispetto a un fenomeno
hanno l'effetto complessivo di diminuire
l'intelligenza e di far sbagliare la
folla nell'individuare il peso il peso
dell'animale
io credo che questo sia un fatto
interessante che ci fa capire come le
forze come diciamo in media che danno
una visione unilaterale piuttosto che il
marketing personalizzato che vuole
costringerci il profili tutti i tool di
qualche modo uguali perché sono
funzionali a venderci cose all estremo
disuguaglianza che da all'elite che una
grande capacità di
promuovere pensieri unici specialmente
in ambito economico sono tutte forze che
in qualche modo contrastano la diversità
e quindi contrastano l'intelligenza
collettiva perché il primo messaggio la
prima storia ci dice da tanti piccoli a
dati grandi che diversità è intelligenza
collettiva
la seconda storia che fare col benessere
e qui ora arriviamo ai big data
arriviamo ad atti come quelli di cui
parlava luca prima a dati che ad esempio
rappresentano l'intera registrazioni
delle chiamate telefoniche infatti da
tutti gli inglesi nel corso di un anno
ci rivela ad esempio le reti di
relazioni che esistono fra le persone
d'accordo per questo esperimento questo
è un collega inglese nel 2010 ha fatto
questo questa misurazione ha calcolato
per ciascuna persona il livello di
diversificazione dei contatti sociali
cosa sta a indicare possiamo misurare
con con un valore con una formula
matematica di entropia che non è neanche
particolarmente complicata quest'idea
molto semplice una persona che chiama
sempre le stesse persone a una bassa
diversificazione una persona che chiama
invece spesso una platea di persone
diverse
a una ampia diversificazione dei
contatti sociali
questo possiamo riassumere con un numero
per ogni persona e possiamo aggregare
questo numero sul territorio sulla
comunità locale su comune sulla
provincia ottenendo un valore di
diversificazione sociale di entità
geograficamente riferite qual è la
sorpresa
cosa ci dice questo questo grafico in
alto ci dice che se noi prendiamo da un
lato l'indicatore di diversificazione
sociale e dall'altra invece un valore di
ben essere misurato con strumenti
tradizionali
in questo caso un indice di povertà di
deprivazione misurato ogni 5 6 7 anni
dall istat britannico si vede che c'è
una fortissima correlazione cioè
maggiore diversità maggiore benessere
un fatto che nel nostro laboratorio
abbiamo potuto confermare ma addirittura
rendere ancora più forte considerando
nulla diversificazione dei contatti
sociali e mara divenuti
diversificazione del movimento l'ipotesi
è questa in un territorio in cui le
persone hanno una grande
diversificazione di movimento potrebbe
essere un territorio che offre molte
opportunità molte cose da fare i bar che
in fin dei conti perché ci muoviamo la
mobilità è l'hardware delle nostre
esistenze no ci muoviamo per fare le
nostre attività
stamattina siamo mossi tutti quanti
prevenire qua e svolgere un'attività di
questo tipo
un territorio che da una grande entropia
diversificazione il movimento è
verosimile che sia un territorio una
comunità che offre maggiori opportunità
un esperimento su larga scala che stiamo
conducendo presto pubblicheremo
risultati mostra esattamente questo
fatto mostra che se noi
l'esperimento è fatto in francia quando
leinster e com e stiamo andando ad
analizzare sempre utilizzando dati di
tipo telefonico quindi le registrazioni
non il contenuto ovviamente la
registrazione delle nostre chiamate dove
e quando abbiamo chiamiamo chi e andiamo
a misurare fondamentalmente ogni persona
o ad ogni territorio
quanta variabilità di movimento mostra
scopriamo di nuovo delle correlazioni
statistiche fortissimi fortissime
vorrei che fosse chiaro a tutti cosa non
voglio intimorire con concetti
statistici che peraltro non sono neanche
particolarmente complessi vuole
semplicemente dire che a maggior tasso
in questo grafico di quella che occupa
viene chiamata entropia di movimento
diversificazione diversità di movimento
corrispondono maggiori indicatori di
benessere sia di carattere materiale
come maggiore reddito pro capite
così come corrispondono migliori
condizioni di eco sistema in termini di
di vissuto complessivo questo questa
misurazione di ecologiche all
deprivation index indice di povertà
ecologica è fondamentalmente una misura
combinata che tiene conto di molti
fattori che
descrivono il benessere di un territorio
bene quello che ci dice questo questa
ricerca che fondamentalmente il
il grado di degrado di un territorio
diminuisce fortissimamente con la
l'entropia con la diversificazione del
movimento il messaggio di questa parte
fondamentalmente è che di questa seconda
storia questo sì basata su grandi dati
che ci permettono di reagire grandi
fenomeni a livello sociale è che la
diversità e il benessere sono
strettamente collegati in un senso vero
misurabile e questo mi porta alla morale
di questa storia mi porta a dire quant'è
importante poter cominciare a pensare a
ai big data
questo non è una figura qualunque non è
semplicemente una bella figura questa è
sono queste la toscana a pisa dalla
costa e firenze vedete come i nostri
movimenti disegnano i territori che ci
abitiamo in qualche modo uno degli
esperimenti che abbiamo fatto nel nostro
laboratorio è lasciare che così come i
signori di dalton all'inizio votavano
per decidere il peso della vacca i
nostri viaggi votano per delimitare i
territori che abitiamo come esperienza
che abbiamo fatto è stato capire qual è
la delimitazione del territorio che in
qualche modo nasce ed è suggerita dal
modo con cui noi viaggiamo e fini con
cui noi facciamo le nostre attività e
abbiamo creato una mappa del dl della
geografia e dei confini suggeriti da
dalla nostra attività
perché il punto è che siamo tutti i
pollicini digitali lasciamo le nostre
briciole col nostro vivere e andando ad
analizzare questi briciole
siamo in grado di capire moltissimo
molte storie su su la nostra il nostro
territorio il nostro vivere questa ad
esempio è la zona intorno pisa lucca
livorno nella mattina di un giorno
possibile sono le sette del mattino si
sta svegliando la
quel territorio vedete i viaggi delle
macchine che arrivano che si spostano e
diventano pallini rosa dove parcheggia
noi vediamo fondamentalmente il ritmo il
pulsare il vivere di un di un posto ad
un livello di dettaglio o di
comprensione che era assolutamente
inarrivabile impossibile da raggiungere
fino a poco fa da questo possiamo siamo
in grado di poter trarre moltissimo in
formazione informazione su come la gente
arriva nei luoghi quali sono i quali è
veramente la mappa urbana del nostro
vivere quotidiano
questo e parigi invece è una
visualizzazione dei dati telefonici
questo è un giorno speciale a parigi c'è
la festa della musica
sono tanti i concertini nelle piazze
intorno nella e questi fuochi
d'artificio che vedete sono
semplicemente gli spostamenti che le
persone fanno da una parte all'altra
della città tracciati attraverso
l'attività telefonica vedete si fa sera
la gente comincia a andare da una piazza
all'altra e c'è tutto questo flusso
incredibile di attività e di complessità
che può essere in qualche modo anche
visivamente vista in cui gli abitanti si
mescolano con i visitatori si riescono
con i pendolari e eccetera ma è
fondamentale e voglio chiudere su questo
pensare che per avere di detta come bene
comune
avere la possibilità di accedere da
parte non soltanto degli scienziati ma
anche dei cittadini dei giovani che
potrebbero creare nuovi servizi nuovi
business su questi dati è fondamentale
che questa conoscenza che noi tutti
creiamo con il nostro vivere diventi
bene comune diventi la possibilità di
poter essere condivisa usate in
sicurezza ovviamente ma può diventare
una delle linfe importanti per una nuova
idea di progresso come diceva luca
all'inizio è fondamentale però cambiare
modello trovare un modello europeo
diverso all'uso di questi dati gafà sta
per google amazon facebook apple quel
modello leaf in cui si centralizzano
tutti i dati e poi fondamentalmente le
usa solamente un latifondista della
conoscenza per fare un applicazione sola
marketing personalizzato venderci cose
più efficacemente è un grande spreco di
opportunità un terribile spreco di
opportunità così come lo è utilizzare
soltanto per fare sicurezza nazionale ma
è possibile non è questa l'unica via è
possibile anche andare oltre a questa
via riportare le persone e le imprese le
istituzioni
al centro di questa storia perché primo
è possibile liberare questi dati in
sicurezza con privacy by design e
rendere queste applicazioni è questa
analitica assolutamente disponibile in
sicurezza e secondo è possibile un nuovo
di nuovo patto sui dati personali in cui
le persone diventino non semplicemente
soggetti passivi che vengono spiati ma
soggetti che partecipano consapevolmente
condividono il loro dati con solamente
con chi è degno di fiducia e
contribuiscono a sviluppare nuove
possibilità di nuovi servizi e siccome
le idee camminano sulle facce delle
persone queste sono le facce dei giovani
e meno che lavorano nel nostro gruppo di
ricerca grazie